am 31 oktober 2009 10 fand in der
markthalle in wien die lotterien
sporthilfe gala statt
diese gala ist jedes jahr das
gesellschaftliche highlight im
österreichischen sport kalender im
rahmen der gala werden österreichs top
sportler für ihre herausragenden
leistungen im abgelaufenen sportjahr
geehrt auch die heeressportler gehören
immer wieder zu den top anwärter für die
begehrten auszeichnungen auch heuer
konnten sich die heeres
leistungssportler freuen
generalstabschef general robert rieger
zeigte sich über den erfolg sehr erfreut
der leistungssport hat einen hohen
stellenwert wir versuchen wir maximal zu
unterstützen wir haben 250
heeressportler und wenn uns diesen
jahres sportlern zwei so leistungsfähige
damen hervorgehen ist es großartig
[Musik]
aufsteiger des jahres ist verena brenner
macht mich wahnsinnig stolz im unter so
vielen sportlern die auszeichnung zu
gewinnen wie hätten sie es genauso wird
in mamas tolle leistungen brachte und
von dem er macht sich freuen wir uns
also dem die teilnehmer der sportlerin
des jahres ist man ist so herzer so ohne
bundesheer können das ganze nicht machen
weil eben und die preisgelder und
einfach der sport bild so klein nicht in
österreich dass man davon so leben
könnte und das bundesheer schaffen ist
die ganze saison zu planen
der romand wo aus sie meinen namen
aufgerufen habe dann habe ich zu meinem
mann robert capa tränen in den augen
gehabt es wagen jetzt mein besonderer
moment
[Musik]